What's up, Marvel fans?
I'm joined by Paula Newsome.
How's it going?
It's going great.
This is terribly exciting.
INTERVIEWER: You
know, we don't know
too much about your character.
What's it like joining the MCU?
You know what I'm
going to tell you that--
[LAUGHTER]
--when Twitter started,
kind of, going agog,
they thought I was MJ's mama.
Not to say that I'm not.
You know what I'm saying?
But what's really fun about
this is joining this--
it's like coming into halftime
when the-- when the game is
already going and you jump in.
And it's like, I got to keep up.
I got to keep up.
It's fabulous.
Well, I bet you did amazing.
Thank you.
So everyone knows that
Peter Parker is Spider-Man.
How does your character
feel about that?
You know, she's not
so enthused by him.
I'm not going to
give away too much.
INTERVIEWER: And that's the tea.
That's true.
She doesn't much
like him that much
because he's not impressed.
I mean, what do you got?
What do you got?
Whoa.
I-- I'm taking that.
I'm going to keep--
I'm going to hold that while
I go into the theaters.
What are you excited
to see tonight?
I'm excited to see the
movie in its entirety.
Jon Watts, our
director, is amazing.
I got to work with an
amazing group of actors,
Fred Molina, Tom, you know.
We were there for a month in
the middle of Atlanta, just--
[LAUGHTER]
--and along with
my stunt double.
It was just-- I look forward
to seeing the whole thing.
You know, the whole
multiverse vibe, come on now.
I mean, you chose a
great time to show up.
I'm just saying.
Well, I don't want to keep you.
You have the rest of
the red carpet to go.
And-- and enjoy the film.
Congratulations again.
Thanks, love.
[MUSIC PLAYING]